[reading]
'The museum is submitting proposals to several
foundations in the hope to gain funds to
build a tropical butterfly conservatory.
So we have either an error up here
or we have no error.
So the part that, as you can tell,
even when I read it I had a little bit
of trouble with, is when we read
'In the hope TO gain'.
Normally when you're talking about
'hope' you would say 'in the hope OF'
whatever the hope is part of.
So in this case 'in the hope of GAINING funds'.
You wouldn't really say
'In the hope TO gain funds'.
So this one I would change to
'In the hope of GAINING funds
to build a tropical butterfly conservatory.'
So I'd put the error here in D.
'in the hope TO gain'
You're 'in the hope OF' something
not 'in the hope TO' something.